In January 2021, General Motors made a stunning announcement.
It aspires to eliminate tailpipe emissions from new light-duty vehicles by 2035,...
…meaning that GM intends to stop selling gas burning cars.
GM executives have made announcements over the past several years...
…touting the carmaker's commitment to an all electric future.
Of course, rivals such as Tesla, the world's most valuable automaker by a long shot,...
…sell nothing but electric cars.
GM plans to introduce 30 EVs by 2025.
They can't just sit back and wait for the market to come.
They are going to have to push the market forward...
…because if they don't do it, there are others who will.
GM executives emphasized the company's plan to be completely emission free...
...is a goal and not a guarantee.
But even with the walk back, GM's plan has skeptics.
Concerns linger among auto industry insiders...
…that consumers are still skittish about buying EVs.
We really want to hear from those customers...
…because we think we can address all of that skeptics.
Vehicle ranges are improving,...
…but charging an EV still takes a lot longer than filling a gas tank.
And many areas, don't have a lot of charging stations,...
…especially when compared with the number of gas stations.
GM is not the only one that has made a big commitment to electric vehicles,...
…but some other automakers are spreading their bets out among electric,...
…hybrid, and even more efficient internal combustion engines.